[Music]
my name is elif sarakan
i'm an anthropologist and also a part of
the an activist of the kurdish women's
movement
i was hoping that we might talk about um
how the kurdish movement um
embraced women's equality as a cause and
as a as a part of its um
defining features the kurdish movements
became to
embrace women's liberation women's
freedom
as essentially a central part of its
movement of its cause and of its aims um
a lot sooner than many people think and
know
actually the women's
liberation movement was very
instrumental in the development of the
kurdish movement as a whole
and therefore the resistance of women
within
the kurdish movement was always a very
uh crucial and instrumental part of
uh fighting for a better not just
kurdistan but also
not just middle east but you know
potentially the whole world
and so therefore you know from women's
resistance from
um whether it's an armed struggle in
uh social spheres in cultural spheres
you know all of these became
the more they became developed the more
it was undeniable
that women had to be a central part
of any liberation and therefore
you know along with abdullah jalan the
architect behind
the paradigm of the kurdish freedom
movement and
pioneering women women like sakina
junsus
and others who founded the kurdish
movement alongside her
with these thoughts and the analysis
that they started to
explore and research that patriarchy and
therefore male dominance is at the very
root of all forms of dominance and
therefore
to overcome oppression and suppression
and enslavement in many ways
and to be able to have a free society
women's liberation must be at the center
so this in some ways was caused
by uh the resistance of women within the
kurdish movement within kurdish society
but also it's becoming a central
central uh part of the kurdish movement
was introduced and proposed by the
kurdish people's leader abdullah jalan
so in terms of actual historical dates
when was the start of um women's
liberation movement within the kurdish
movement
so you know kurdish people women all
around the world have been
resisting for thousands of years but in
terms of the kurdish movement
so the kurdish movement itself was
founded in 1978 they were organizing and
mobilizing throughout
uh the earlier part of the 70s and
officially founding them
founded themselves in 1978 where women
were involved in this founding as well
and you know throughout the years
women were instrumental parts of
mobilizing
the kurdish society all around kurdistan
particularly in the south east of turkey
and therefore through this resistance
the first um autonomous women's
army of the kurdish movement was created
in
1993 and 1994
and so through being able to defend
their own homelands
themselves autonomously with their own
with their own
uh fighters and with their own
commanders
this in some ways created the confidence
and the ability to be able to then
propose and come up with um the women's
liberation
program in some ways and therefore they
created women's liberation
parties for all of all for all over uh
kurdistan and you know the middle east
but also for kurdish people in europe
and other parts of the world as well
and through this resistance then in 2005
abdullah jalan who is the founder and
the leader of the kurdish movement but
also the architect behind this paradigm
founded so the proposed
the alternative paradigm of democratic
confederalism
so even though the discussion was
happening for a long time within the
kurdish movement
the official declaration that the
kurdish
freedom movement will will overcome
the demand of an independent state but
rather work towards democratic
confederalism
based on the principles of direct
democracy
gender liberation and ecology this
came this was officially declared in
2005
and therefore the idea around this was
you know not only are women instrumental
uh
to the liberation of a society but a
society can't be free without women's
liberation that's a
direct quote of abdullah and therefore
if patriarchy and male dominance are at
the root of the nation state
we if we want full and genuine
liberation we need to
we need to overcome the demands and the
efforts towards building a nation-state
so rather than building new borders the
aim is to
deem current borders obsolete and
therefore be able to dismantle all forms
of dominance and be able to work towards
a genuine alternative for society
for the kurdistan for the middle east
and maybe even the whole world
so what happened in the early 1990s that
determined
women to take arms and create the
women's army
the in the early 90s the way women
taking up arms
in some ways came about was you know in
1984 the kurdish freedom movement
uh started an armed struggle against
its colonizers and this was a mixed army
so women and men
fighting alongside against the
colonizing armies
as many people may or may not know
kurdistan is an international colony so
it's divided into four nations states
turkey iran iraq and syria
and so therefore the struggle had to be
uh multi-dimensional in terms of
in terms of uh direction in terms of
area in terms of understanding um
and so on and so women were always an
instrumental part of this struggle but
what was also really what was also
really important that the more women
joined this struggle and especially the
armed struggle
the more obviously naturally women had
power women had
influence and and therefore
along with having discussions with the
kurdish people's lead up to legend who
was always a genuine
comrade to them a genuine uh
uh you know genuine friend in struggle
to them they were able to
organize autonomously so it was mainly
about women's involvement so women's
mobilizing power
and involvement but also because they
you know had a genuine
friend in comrade like abdullah jalan
how big is his role within within the
movement
without a shadow of a doubt the kurdish
movement that we have today and what we
see today the influence
of it in terms of the fight against isis
the alternative paradigm
uh the women's liberation ideology
without a shadow of a doubt abdel john
is the architect of that
so yeah he has an absolutely
crucial foundational and central role
not just for the kurdish movement for
but for millions of kurdish people
they see him as their leader because
they see him as
the person who in some ways created the
resurrection of their identity
after centuries of oppression
suppression massacres and genocide
this person came along you know and was
able to mobilize
organize and uh direct people towards
a liberation paradigm that wouldn't just
uh create a society or
a quote unquote freedom based on
nationalism
but create genuine liberation that was
for all peoples of that society
um and so yeah without a shadow of a
doubt abdullah john is
the architect the philosopher and the
thinker behind this ideology
and did he become a leader of the
movement since 1975 when the movement
started
yeah he abdullah founded the kurdish
movement in
the early 1970s when he was in
uh when he spent time in ankara which is
the capital of turkey
and met many other kurdish people as
well actually and turkish people too
uh people from the black sea region in
turkey and he was able to mobilize them
and bring them together to to be able to
create this movement
and how come it took 20 years
for women to join the movement
um as an autonomous kind of group that
would
that supported him where were women's
rights
a subject um that he was concerned with
from the early 70s was it before or
after
women actually started supporting him
and it took arms
abdullah john always says that he
questioned
the position of women in society from a
very
early uh from from like very early on
so his idea of
um you know especially kurdish women's
position
in society was in some ways one of the
most
one of the motivating factors of why he
wanted to start this movement in the
first place you know he gives examples
from
his mom and other people that he
lived with and lived around when he was
growing up
so women were certainly involved from
the very beginning of the kurdish
movement from the seventies
uh you know especially women like sakina
johnson's and others like her
um but being it but organizing
autonomously
was something that you know they
had to and therefore did create the
foundations for
so for it not to just be kind of like
tokenism that
you know look we're allowing women to
organize but it had to be something that
was genuine and
could be set in stone and could set a
precedent as well
so you know the the position of women
was discussed from a very early a
from a very early time even in the first
founding congress of the kurdish
movement in 1978 the position of women
was discussed and there were women
involved in that congress
that found in congress as well but the
and they were always
somewhat autonomous in a way that they
would go out and do the mobilizing and
organizing
you know some more autonomously but
actually creating the
paradigm and ideology around women's
liberation
did come afterwards and that was
developed through reading writing
researching
understanding experience in revolution
and in struggle that came about over
time
um you it's obviously absolutely fine to
say no
but i was wondering whether you might
want to share that story with
um women being going to the top of the
mountain and
blackmailing the male soldiers
yes so there's a story there's a story
that is told quite often in the kurdish
movement and particularly in the kurdish
women's movement
of the first experience of women taking
up arms
and how a lot of them well not maybe not
well a lot of the male uh
you know comrades kind of
how what it meant to them and how they
accepted it or what their
attitude was towards it and there was a
story where
that was told that that gets told quite
often where a group of
uh guerilla fighters are about to go out
to an operation and
they the male commander says to the
women you should stay back
and you know prepare food for us for
when we come back
in the mountains and so they go to this
operation and get
surrounded by uh the
um the the you know soldiers
of the uh of the enemy
army and so they're kind of trapped and
there's no there's not really
much of a way that they can escape or
even come back
let alone complete the operation so they
radio into the women and saying you need
to come and save us
so at first they say no we're not gonna
come because you didn't want to
want us to go to this operation in the
first place and of course you know it's
their comrades so they do go in the end
and because of this slight resistance
the male
the commander threatens them with taking
their
arms from them so their guns from them
and resisting that because for them
it's not necessarily about the gun
itself but it's about
what that gun symbolizes for them and
therefore their right to defend their
land and in some ways then therefore
they're right to themselves
and so to resist that the group of women
uh run to the top of a mountain
and say if anyone comes up we're gonna
shoot them
and someone some people try to come up
and they actually shoot at them they
you know obviously deliberately miss uh
so no one actually gets shot but
then another slightly um so
someone sends them a note saying you
know this particular person wants to
come and visit you and it's someone that
they really respect so then they say
okay we will allow him to come up and by
time they get to the top of the
mountain they realize that they were
tricked and it wasn't that person that
they trust and
uh that person's name was just used as a
way to get up to them
so then these these men essentially
imprisoned them in the mountains that
there's i i imagine that there's they
have their own prisons
and and they um
so they so then they somehow get them no
alto after large alarm
just telling him about the situation and
he immediately makes the call and says
you better free them right now.
and the people who imprison these women
say but you know they they try to shoot
at us and they tried they
threatened us with not saving us from an
operation
and so on and he says if if my
women comrades did something they did it
knowing
knowingly and they did it for good
reason so you better free them right now
and
don't ever threaten them by taking their
guns away from them and yeah there's
many examples
and stories that are told in exactly how
in practical terms after
john was a comrade to these people
and in terms of um women's participation
in the um kurdish movement beyond
guns how are women's
rights defended how do they participate
in
the decision making etc
the decision makes so every so the way
the kurdish movement organizes
is in assembly structures and so that's
where all decisions are made is at the
very bottom level and
at assembly level and every assembly has
a co-chair structure where it's a man
and a woman
and therefore and also each assembly has
a minimum 40
quota for women and alongside that
parallel to that there's
autonomous women's structures that have
veto power over decisions that are made
in
the general assemblies and so
this is how this this the structures you
know there's committees for
you know committees vary depending on
the need of that particular assembly and
where it's based
but yeah that's how it's in some ways
institutionalizes through assembly
structures
so how many assemblies are there and how
big is
an assembly what kind of criterium
uniting one assembly i mean this i think
you nee you need
i think there needs to be a minimum 21
people to make an assembly to be able to
uh kind of declare declare to make be
able to make a declaration as an
assembly
i couldn't say how many assemblies exist
because
definitely hundreds there's i know
there's at least
300 kurdish people's assemblies across
europe so i can't say how many there are
in kurdistan or in northern syria
there's
prob there's like definitely in its
thousands uh there's many many
assemblies
and um yeah so you need i think
it's minimum 21 people to be able to be
an assembly and it
it's usually better for it to be an odd
number when it so for you know
decision making and
yeah there's there is kind of like a
general guide to what a
in a way the constitution of an assembly
will be but you can also somewhat adjust
that to your locality and what the needs
of that assembly might be
and are they designed according to
abdullah jalan's
um writings or yes so the assembly
proposal
come came from of the legion exactly how
it's been put into practice is
you know obviously gets transformed and
changed with the times
because society is also transforming all
the time as well
um but yeah the proposal definitely came
from up to largely
he's obviously been a leader of the
movement for so many years has his
ideology changed throughout the um the
decades
so the kurdish movement started
actually on a as a marxist lendis
movement
in the late late 60s early 70s
in some ways mainly because that was the
environment global environment then as
well the 68 movement
you know the idea of class struggle and
so on and so forth
and also you know not to mention some of
the you know some of the
logistical factors may be dismissed
quite easily of
you know having literature available to
you in kurdish and in turkish
so these are also important factors as
well of things getting translated into
these language
and therefore access to you know that
kind of literature and knowledge
um and analysis but yeah it's kind of
but it was always
questioning and like was was quite
critical
of the idea of states uh from the very
beginning
it was kind of a preliminary model to be
able to get started i would say
and the discussions around what and how
the movement could transform its
structures
was happening very early on uh but it
certainly has transformed from that to
a um you know as we call it democratic
confederalist movement
and um the kind of the idea of no
borders
allows for all of these assemblies and
communities to organize themselves
across various nation states and
[Music]
and to kind of develop their own rules
that they would
follow and then what happens when those
rules
kind of conflict with the rules of the
national state
well i mean that's an important so you
know it depends where you are like if
you're in northern syria
then the administration is also
organized on that basis
if you're in somewhere like london then
of course there is an existing state
so you make decisions about your own
commun community and
you you create you make sure you have
these alternatives
as for if and when there is a
transformation in the stakes structure
in this country
or there is the dismantling of the state
in this country
because you know it's not like every
state every system in the world
has changed and transformed in history
so it's not like the nation state
is here to stay because it's also on the
scale of history
and humanity it's a very very new
phenomenon for us
it's about i think it's about 400 years
old or something which is
very new final question um
the kurdish movement has
um had to be violent
to some extent and i was wondering
whether
um you see that as a consequence of
the geography and the kind of regional
politics
um surrounding kurdistan
um and whether non-violence
is at all possible for the kurdish
i think it's important to understand or
do
you know when we talk about violence
because you know obviously
violence and the definit you know
violence isn't just physical violence
there's structures of violence there's
systems of violence
um so you know when we if
just because there's the absence of
physical violence in a
in a country like even here for example
it doesn't mean there aren't structures
of violence
um in the u.s you know having
having abortion banned in a state that
is a system and structure of violence
and you know in that case it's obviously
a direct physical effect
on people but you know austerity is a
structure of violence
um and so on and so forth so you know i
think
you know when we talk about violence
especially in the kurdish case
you know it's never been violent in an
offensive way it's been self-defense
you know the kurdish movement and
therefore the guerilla
uh guerrillas or the guerrilla army
um or the units have never gone on
on offensive attacks or wars to invade
somewhere else it's always about it's
been about
defending defending its people and
defending its
lands so in that sense yes it's it's
it's been a necessary and unfortunately
necessary
uh aspect of the self-defense has been
the use
of violence in some ways but it's it's
been necessary because
you know whether it's the whether we see
from the examples whether it's the
mothers of peace or
people demonstrating on on streets
um and therefore the violent repression
of the you know in that case the turkish
state against it
you know dragging mothers across the
floor who are peacefully demonstrating
who um you know when there's
demonstrations
tear-gassing people when people
democratically
run for whether it's me as mayors or mps
imprisoning them as you know so-called
terrorists
even though they were democratically
elected you know in many ways
that kind of leaves you that kind of
takes away the option of
non-violence from you even though it's
still tried and it's
there is still that going on and the aim
is always for peace and it always should
be for peace because
when there isn't pieces people you know
in places like the middle east is people
like the kurds and
and um other oppressed peoples of the
world wherever there may be ones who are
affected the most
so the aim is for peace but
unfortunately sometimes in achieving
that
certain methods don't work
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you